remarkable is the word used to describe
something extraordinary something or
someone who makes a mark cements a
change and in this case gives a chance
paulita Simpson is giving a voice to our
youth by providing a safe space where
they could just be using the Arts as a
vessel of Hope
I want you to be right there with me
it's not a lesson about hitting the
right notes that comes later it's a
lesson about finding Harmony within
yourself and supporting others on their
Journey
Simpson says she formed her non-profit
positively Arts out of necessity we
needed to create a space where kids have
the time and we have the ears to listen
here she uses Visual and Performing Arts
as the conduit of change feelings of I'm
not good enough I'm not pretty enough
I'm not smart enough I'm not enough and
she says it's taken years to create a
curriculum that offers a true foundation
for transformation I feel like I took
everything I learned from my childhood
and Disney and Sesame Street in Harvard
and I put it in this package that is
simply just an extended
family is it bringing you Joy where are
you in the journey good Joy songwriting
equals Joy thank you for sharing it
along the way I discovered the perfect
recipe on how do I ensure that a child
leaves this building feeling more
empowered than when they walked in 13
year old Abby quit the walked into
positively Arts three years ago a cancer
survivor in remission I love flita she
was literally like a savior to me she
came during some of my darkest times and
probably brought back a smile that I
probably never had before Abby is a
talented young singer
here
but it positively Arts it's not about
creating the next Superstar probably 50
percent of the kids who come here if you
ask them what do you want to be when
they grow up it's not a performer it's
simply about helping that child find his
or her own inner strength and voice
when you build that child's social and
emotional development and you focus on
creating a resilient child they will be
successful in whatever they do I knew it
was good for her but you know how good
it was going to be for her Abby's dad
Omar says this experience has been
life-changing for his daughter I don't
even think it's about singing or you
know making a great artist because who
knows what the future holds for for her
but what I'm seeing how she's becoming a
better human
she
she's you know so different from where
she was before about 70 percent of the
students at positively Arts are on
tuition assistance polita says no one is
turned away and she knows firsthand how
helpful the Arts can be she lost her
father when she was 13 and eventually
found sanctuary in singing I want to be
that place so people don't have to
struggle like my mom did and that kids
don't have to struggle the way I did
here they're finding balance striking
the right chord and writing their
chapter of today
[Music]
these kids aren't just surviving they're
thriving every day I wake up I just
think of it as like a new opportunity
like to grow to learn something new
we're the place that turns dreams into
plans
positively Arts quite a place so many
different vehicles for these kids
whether it be you know the type of art
that you can draw and design or sing and
perform but that's not the goal the goal
is to create positive outlook and know
who you are and they're doing that yeah
the Arts just the vehicle there's a
confidence that comes from being able to
express yourself in that business I know
who you are and be confident with that
love it yeah and you can see that Dad he
knew he could tell the difference in his
daughter and his child he gave me
goosebumps it's a little teary-eyed
after that interview wow that's
wonderful of course